A discrimination tree is
a knowledge structure,
in which the cases themselves
are the leaf nodes of the tree.
At the root node, and at all
the intimated nodes are questions.
The questions of the root node and
the intimidated node pertain
to the pertain to the indexical
structures of the cases.
So recall that,
we were using the origins of the cases
as the index equal structure.
Let's stay with that point
just a while longer.
So now I might have a question that the
root node which says is the origin not
of 5N?
If the answer to that question is yes,
then it brings us to this branch.
If the answer is no,
it takes us to the other branch.
At this node I might ask,
is the origin east of 5 of E?
If yes, it brings us to this branch.
If no, it brings us to that branch.
In this way we are able to
discriminate between C and
A, in fact we able to disconnect
with C not all of the cases.
Similarly for this part of the graph.
So now that we have learned,
what is the knowledge structure
discrimination trees for
organization the case memory, let us now
look at how will we store a new case.
How will we incrementally learn this
knowledge structure as new cases are put
into the case library?
Imagine that there is a new case, X.
So we can navigate this tree using X.
Is the origin of X North of 5 of A?
Yes it is.
So we come to this branch.
Is the origin of X East of 5 of E?
No it is not, so we come to this branch.
But now we have a problem.
Both A and X, have the same
answer no to this question.
We must find a way of
discriminating between A and X, so
we'll add a new question here.
Perhaps we can add a new question.
Is the origin East of 3 of E?
In the case of X, the answer is yes.
In the case of A, the answer is no.
That's why adding a right
node at the right place,
we have found a way of
discriminating between X and A.
This now is a modified
discrimination tree.
Each time we add a location to memory,
the organization of
the case of memory changes.
This is an example of
incremental learning,
with the addition of each case some
new knowledge structure is learned.
We learn more about incremental
learning in the next lesson.
>> So going back to our programming
example, we were dealing with cases
of file input, and we could use
the same indexical structure
according to which we organize our cases
to now design a discrimination tree.
At the very top level I would probably
ask, what language is the casing?
Is it in Java, C++, Python?
Now the discrimination trees don't have
to be binary like they are right here.
We can have more than
two answers coming out.
So at the top level, I could have
a question of what language is the case
in, and the branches could be JAVA,
C++, and Python, and so on.
I could similarly have questions about,
is it an efficient solution, is it for
a big problem or a small problem,
is it for my personal use or is it for
consumer use, and so on until I get
down to individual cases that represent
different things I might want to
consider when I'm doing a new solution.
>> David a point you make about this
not being a but a very important one.
Let's go back to our original example,
where we had a micro world of blocks and
the blocks had different colors.
So I can ask a question at the root
node, what is the color of the block?
And have a large number of branches
coming out of it corresponding
to different colors.
Here's an example of a discrimination
tree, not a binary print.